on today's show we're going to talk
about dealing with anger issues we're
going to talk about how to influence
your friends and help them make better
decisions
we're going to talk about family
enabling when grandparents
enable mom enables kids and the
loop-de-loop-de-loop stay tuned
hey what's up i'm john and this is the
dr john dalone show i hope you're doing
well
hope your world's working out all right
hope your friends and family still like
you
i guess they should love you they don't
have to like you today but we'll just
all get through whatever today's gonna
be together it's a beautiful day here in
nashville tennessee
and i'm so glad that you've joined us
thanks for hanging out
we're gonna talk about anything and
everything on today's show so
if you want to be on this show if you
want to call in
with real challenges going on in your
life real celebrations going on in your
life
give me a call at 1-844-693-3291
it's four four six nine three three two
nine one
or you can go to johndaloni.com show
fill out the form
and it will go to kelly i would not do
that today because she's not in a super
great mood because she's been in traffic
since early and i made one little joke
and i just saw her mouth
through the glass not today john not
today
and usually that's when i hit the gas
and i'm like oh definitely today
but the way she said it i got the
message loud and clear
not today john not today and so i'm just
looking at this camera because she's
over
to my left um everything's in a box to
the left
including my heart but i'm looking
straight ahead in the camera today
because i don't want to make eye contact
with her because i think it will burn my
rods and cones in my eyeballs
and listen last night this is super
funny it made me laugh uh we had a
little league game
that i went to and it was so fun hey you
know what i just decided i'm gonna start
having fun at little league games
because i was like the dad who gets all
worked up to how my son's doing
and then i just decided to learn all the
other kids names and just cheer
rambunctiously and it's turned into the
most
fun it's cheaper than a movie actually
not because little league cost about 11
million dollars to sign a kid up
nowadays
but i was just cheering with my wife and
it was a lot of fun
but i peeled off a little bit early
right when the game was over
and brought my daughter home and then i
said hey you gotta brush your teeth
and wash your hands go bathroom and then
i'll tuck you in
so she yelled daddy i'm ready to get
tucked in and i went in there
to kiss her good night we just have this
i mean robotic
nighttime routine and as i walked in she
was
swinging from her bunk bed
and right when i walked in she swung out
at me like this
like flying karate move and she said dad
when you come in to kiss me i'm gonna
kick you in the face like this and she
went whoosh
and i was just looking at her thinking
that was super unnecessary like there's
nothing
there's i don't know why you would do
that and then i thought
oh my gosh yes one day somebody's gonna
have a crush on you
and they're gonna walk into some room
and think
i'm gonna make my kiss move on josephine
and she's already got this thing worked
out she will fly whoever you are
and kick you in the face she's been
prepping for years hopefully lots and
lots of years
but whoever tries to lean in suckers
she will karate chop you in the face so
to all you parents out there
who just want to love your child before
bedtime
and they decide they're going to kick
you in the face the show's for you
all right let's go to richard in not so
normal illinois what's up richard how
are we doing man
i'm pretty good how are you doctor john
good i
that was about a fourth or fifth grade
joke i just made on
behalf of your city do people call it
not so normal all the time or not really
i there's a lot of stuff that people
call normal not
oh my gosh like my work life right and
my marriage is not normal either
we could do this all day man what's up
so
i am a christian a father three and a
husband and i struggle with anger issues
and
yeah so that's my question how come how
can i deal with that
having two younger kids and then one
almost teenager
and if you have any questions please ask
yeah man that's
i love how simply you put that yet how
complex all the things you just rolled
out are
um who taught you to be angry
uh so i don't want to throw my dad under
the bus but
hey come on throw him he's not listening
richard
let's be real he's not listening i mean
i remember him being
quite angry a lot of times and having a
short fuse and i feel like i'm the same
way
and my son's five and i see i just see
that in him too
and my wife can get angry sometimes too
and we're just kind of navigating this
giant ocean we call life
as best we can okay so you picked it you
you your dad loved you probably a good
human being and he was an angry guy and
those aren't all mutually exclusive we
like to just
dump people in these buckets like
terrible or
awesome and almost everybody's more
complex than that right
so it's okay to call out your dad and
still love him right
um and he doesn't need you to defend him
he's a grown man
um so you learned a model of dealing
with
challenges and frustrations that as you
mentioned that we just call life and you
learned
to be angry paint me a picture of what
anger looks like for you
um so i mean so i've been working a lot
in my church
with my small group leader and my my
church friends
on why i get angry about things or how
it goes but usually it's like
i guess i don't get my way and i watch
my kids make mistakes that i've made in
the past
and anger for me is
getting frustrated getting agitated very
easily
and then if people raise their voice at
me i tend to raise my voice back
and that's that's anger for me so take
us all back to when you're seven
or maybe 10 and your dad
lost his mind once just got raged out do
you have an incident that you remember
uh yeah okay pretty bit pretty vividly
too
um paint that picture for us when you're
a little one
well when when i was younger i remember
my mom and my dad fighting one time
and my dad picked up a chair and hit the
wall okay and so
my mom went upstairs and cried and i
didn't understand and i went to be with
her and she was just sad and i didn't
understand what was going on
okay so take us back transport us into
that little boy you saw that chair or
heard that chair smash against the wall
what's in that little boy what's that
little boy feeling
i was pretty scared i kind of went into
a different room and kind of hid
okay like show us where are you hiding
um so i hid in
the living room kind of behind the table
and then
after my mom went upstairs i quietly
went upstairs after my dad left the
house because he left the house after
that
okay so if if we were just to
like distill everything down between a
fight and a flight and a freeze you went
somewhere and got real still
right yeah you were a if you've seen
like the national geographic
with documentaries or whatever you were
the baby deer that curls up real tight
and just gets real still
my mom is dealing with whatever threat
right yep
um now when you think back
on that
are you happy that you're doing that to
your kid
not at all man
because getting mad is okay i'm getting
frustrated if you're not frustrated as a
parent of
a teen and young kids then you've got
some screws loose you probably should go
see a psychiatrist right
that's a frustrating enterprise
and then once you feel that frustration
once you feel that
even getting mad everything after that's
a decision
and i hate to to simplify it so much
because i know people
talk about being trapped by it or
controlled by it and at this point in my
life i don't buy that anymore
especially somebody who knows enough to
know that they're reaching out to people
in accountability groups and are trying
and trying and trying so
the question most of us don't ever ask
is
why are you choosing to repeat this
cycle
so that your kid has to experience that
moment of frozen
terror in a side room because they're
scared of that
what is what is choosing that res that
that outcome what does that
get you just more pain
it doesn't help i know it doesn't help i
just
but you keep doing it so you're getting
something from it what are you getting
from it
i feel i feel like it's control
i seem i feel like i want to control
things really bad i want things to go my
way and i get
i become a child that's angry when i
don't get my way
there you go man and so sometimes we
don't
care enough about ourselves when we're
first in
entering into i want to change my
behavior i want to change my life we
don't care enough about ourselves
and we don't have a model of people who
cared about us right if you the story
you just told
you were hiding in terror from your dad
and then your job was to go make sure
mom was okay
and that's not a seven-year-old's job on
either account
right yeah that's not your job as a
seven-year-old man
do you know what i did this morning and
i'm not making this up for
theater i'm just talking to my friend
richard this morning
i wrote a letter i'm i'm working with a
counselor i'm writing letters to my old
selves
and i wrote a letter to teenage john and
it ended with
go laugh and do stupid teenage things
you're gonna be all right
and i love you and i'm letting these
kids off the hook that
have been protecting me for so long man
and until you let that seven-year-old
be a seven-year-old and not crouch and
terror in your living room
and then have to go take care of mom
because she's broken up
until you can let that kid go he's going
to continue to run your life for you
and he's going to continue to respond
like a seven-year-old does which is
throwing things and pouting and you're
going to pass this along because your
kids are learning this model too
that's the thing i don't want to happen
i know i know you don't
and that's why you got to let that
little kid go man
you gotta let that seven-year-old copy a
seven-year-old
and here's how that starts tonight you
write that little kid a letter
how old are your kids again my daughter
daughter's one my son's five and my
my other daughter's 11. okay so you're
in it right you're exhausted
and you're going to all the events in
the evenings and you got a five-year-old
who's just running a muck right so
you're
and then you have a one-year-old that
just screams all the time and so
you are struggling your marriage is
probably strained right now
you're exhausted and you're trying to
wrap all this up into a pretty little
christian dad
and brother you're tired okay
so here's what i want you to do number
one i want you to prioritize sleep
you've got to for the sake of your
family you have to
set a nighttime alarm and start going to
bed okay
number two i want you to get some time
and i want you to write
that kid a letter the one you just told
us about
and i want you to write it from the
perspective of you
as though you're writing to your
seven-year-old self
and let that kid know no kid should have
to hide in the living room because their
dad is such a child
that he's smashing furniture against a
wall no kid should be that scared of his
dad
and no kids job is to go make sure mom
is okay
because she's an adult she's a grown-up
and grown-ups should be able to work
together to solve problems and not smash
things and scare each other and hide
from one another
and then at the end of that letter i
want you to process all of the way that
kid's feeling and i want you to re-feel
that in your body and then i want you to
let that seven-year-old go play
and then from that moment i want you to
sit down with your wife it may not be
tonight it may be tomorrow or the next
day
and i want you to tell her i'm done
being angry
not done being mad not done being
frustrated right but i'm done being
angry and i'm done
responding like a child i want you to
give her permission to talk into your
life and then i want you to bring your
five and your 11 year old in
and let them know that you've been scary
and that you've been sad
and that you're not gonna be scary and
sad anymore
right and from that moment forward
you're gonna start working on little
tiny things like when you feel yourself
get angry you're going to stop and say
i'm going to step outside and in your
head you're going to think because i'm a
grown-up
i'm not going to pass this on i'm going
to stare down this forest fire of child
of
family trauma and child trauma it stops
with me
and it's gonna be slow and it's gonna be
frustrating and you're gonna have idiots
in your life giving you all kinds of
stupid advice like
you just gotta get that anger out bro if
you try to get the anger out it's gonna
re-groove your brain deeper and become
more and more and more of a default
setting
so you got to build new pathways and it
sucks building new pathways
but you have to because you got an 11
year old and a five-year-old and a
one-year-old and they can't carry this
on for you anymore
right yeah okay
do you have somebody in your life you
trust that's not a [ __ ]
that will walk along with you yeah i've
got two people
for sure and you trust them yeah
absolutely
and they don't give you stupid advice
nope like yeah bro you should be pissed
they give you actual like they chill out
calm down
no they tell me that anger is sinning
and that i need to be careful because
i'll pass it on generationally
okay so anger is not a sin anger is not
bad
what you do with it is a sin yeah acting
like an idiot is acting like an idiot
right definitely yeah being angry is
impo
if you try to stamp out anger dude
you're trying to stamp out all anger
means is that you care about something
it points you in the direction of
something you care about and so when you
see your kid
making a mistake you care that he's not
going to hurt like you hurt
and then your reaction makes sure that
he hurts like you hurt right
so all anger is pointing you in the
direction of something you care about
it's a good thing
it's wired into us right it's like you
just mentioned it's our default setting
it's what we do afterwards
and that my friend is a choice and it's
gonna be hard to change
but your kids are worth it and you are
worth it they are worth it yeah
hey hey hey you richard are worth it
okay you're worth being able to breathe
you're worth being able to sleep you're
worth
not feeling this shame all the time
because you
lost your temper on 11 year old or your
rage angry you're get pro tell me if i'm
wrong
you're able to control it sometimes but
you double down and you compress it in
your chest like a nuclear reactor
so everybody around you feels it but you
can walk through your house with a
little bit high and mighty because
you're not yelling or hitting anything
is that fair yeah yeah dude listen
that's almost worse not quite as bad as
smashing a chair but it's almost as
worse
because your kids feel that tension and
they backfill it with
it must be their fault and you know what
they do they spend the rest of their
life trying to take care of mom
train the rest of their life trying not
to make dad angry and that's not their
job
right so your job is to step outside on
the front porch and breathe
real deep
your job is to get a night's sleep your
job is to start every morning with what
you're grateful for
your job is to feel that anger and know
it's there and know
i love my kids bring it in guys
right your job is to not be immature
and to learn new tactics right
so don't let people tell you that
feeling angry is wrong it's not
smashing stuff in front of your kids is
right yep listen you're a brave guy
richard and i'm really really grateful
for your call
really grateful for your call and if you
can't tell this is the pot talking to
the kettle here and i've worked a long
long time on being angry
and i'm going to tell you right now
there is healing on the other side of
that
i laugh a lot more than i used to men
and i fall asleep most nights
not every night but most nights
and now i love going to little league
games and i used to not be able to go
because i would get all
right and your family
generationally right we talk here at
ramsey solutions about you know change
your family tree when it comes to money
you're going to change your family tree
when it comes to relationships and
anger and peace but i want to circle all
the way back
getting mad that's not always your
choice getting that lightning bolt of
anger
that's rarely your choice everything
after that
is a decision a choice and you my
brother are worth it
your wife is worth it and your three
kids are worth it
thank you so much for that call let's go
to nicholas in
lansing michigan what's up nicholas
hey john how's it going good what's
going on man
hey man i'm looking for some advice um
stemming from uh the peer group i grew
up with
yes um growing up you know all my
friends and i
we all grew up pretty poor i think the
richest of us now as an adult looking
back
was maybe lower middle class
i'm still friends with almost all my
friends from middle school
i just kind of went down a different
path in the military
i started learning about finance
economics and politics
and uh dropped out or finished
the degree i was working on went right
back into school for a completely
separate ip degree
and now i'm uh little after 30 and
i'm obsessed with finance i'm obsessed
with investing i work in i.t and i make
good money i've still got all the same
friends
and not a single one of them has made a
a progressive move in their life in the
last 10 years
and i've been like harping on them and
harping on them and trying
everything i could to like get them with
some sort of vision
goal some sort of progress five year
plan
one year plan anything and i can't get a
single one of them
to care about anything more than how to
maximize their time playing video games
hmm you love those guys huh
yeah frustrating four or five
guys since middle school dude i'm i'm in
the
exact same boat man exact same boat i've
got
some of my friends are as old as i am
like our parents knew each other when
they were pregnant
right yeah dude and you love love love
those guys
and you've been able to turn a corner in
your life that they haven't
um man did y'all have some hilarious
stories growing up
just straight hijinks i mean
not that i'm gonna talk about on air i
don't know what statue of limitations
are
yes yes all right
here's the here's the good of it in the
heart of it okay
those guys love you they don't give a
crap about your job
they love you you're just they're one of
the guys and can i tell you this
and i've learned this how you're just
over 30
yeah i was about 38 or maybe 39 even
um when it finally started leaking out a
little bit
dude your friends are so proud of you
you're the dude that made it
like you got out and when you hear
something like that
you look back at the people that you
love and you're like what are you doing
you can
it's not hard you can just take this
some of them aren't going to because
they choose not to
some of them aren't going to because
their experiences plus their genetics
plus their decisions plus their brain
chemistry plus plus plus
that's just not going to make they're
not going to make it
and they are so proud of you dude and
they love you
and your job is not to make them have a
five year plan
or to make sure that they're not smoking
whatever they're smoking or going to
whatever
your job is just to love them and to
make sure y'all are still laughing and
telling those old jokes
make sure they know you're available if
they need something
and it was a hard conversation with me
with my buddies when i was like hey guys
why don't you guys why don't you guys
and they were like
dude we don't care one of one of my old
gang their dad died went back we all
hung out we all told stories we all
laughed we all drank some and we laughed
some more
and i got to see their parents who are
now old and
um it was a beautiful time and dude
they were just proud of me and they just
love me they're not gonna change their
life
and i know that's hard and frustrating
you may need even more in that
but at the end of the day your job is
just to be their friend
and if they ever do call awesome and if
they don't
awesome right could i
could i ask you a follow-up please do
you ask me anything man
uh so currently i'm spending
um you know through various means
um i'm spending hundreds of dollars a
month
um trying to help them out don't do that
yeah the biggest thing i'm doing right
now is uh my i bought
a a large house which was renovated into
a triplex
yeah and i'm renting out two of the
units to two of my friends
um for after utilities a couple hundred
dollars a month
yeah um and i was hoping that they would
take
you know the extra hundreds of dollars a
month that they would be saving to do
something
intelligent with it and you know for the
first couple of months it worked and now
that it's been
near a year they're doing stuff like
getting
elaborate tattoos that they can't afford
instead of paying down their car that
they couldn't afford and
they're buying new uh gaming you know
video gaming equipment that they can't
afford instead of
you know you know getting their child
into like the extracurricular activities
that they can't afford
so here you go nicholas you can love
them but you can't save them
you can love them but you can't save
them and and and
and there's a tendency to feel guilty
because you got out
because you made some different life
choices don't feel guilty about who
you've become
of the hard work you've worked through
the hard work you've got to come at some
point you're gonna have to be less
obsessed with
accomplishment and achievement and
finance and job
and and and and at some point you're
gonna have to reckon with nicholas
because here's the worst part dude
however successful you become old
nicholas is gonna follow
you around with you until you deal with
him but that's not for today that's not
for this call
but yeah you can love your friends man
but you can't save them
if you've got the disposable income just
to let them live
you can do that i don't mix that kind of
stuff
i don't loan my friends money um i don't
give them money they don't call me for
it either
um if they want to talk through any
situation in their life
if they wanted to call you for some help
with it i'll be there any
anytime and they know that and they call
right
when they're dealing with challenges
with their kids or their family or
whatever
i don't send them a bill these are my
brothers for years and years and years
and years
but i don't send them money and i don't
hire them
right i wouldn't hire them i love them i
wouldn't hire them
and they don't hire me right but you
can't save them and this is going to be
an awkward unwinding of this
right
how you're going to get them out of this
house it's going to be hard huh
well i mean
sometimes they make it feel like it can
be very easy
right because like i've made it clear to
them
you know when they moved in like i'm
trying to help you out
and then you know when for example one
of them
um blows like i think he blew like
400 on his new girlfriend's kids
christmas presents and then was late on
my rent
i know nicholas went down and i was like
dude you're you're spending my
money i'm giving to you as charity
listen that's the problem that's the
problem
that's the problem they're not they're
spending their money
they're spending their money
they are taking your hook up because
brothers hook up brothers but they're
spending their money and that's the
problem with
cutting deals with giving money loaning
money to
friends and family is it creates a wedge
in the relationship
if they were just being idiots getting
tattoos you would sit by them
while they're playing video games and
you'd be like you're an idiot or when
y'all are
grabbing something to eat you'd be like
that's the stupidest thing
but since you are in now in a financial
business relationship with these guys
now you are starting to get into the why
are you spending that's mine that
that's as you just said that's my money
here's the deal nicholas it's not it's
their money
you gave them a good deal on rent so my
recommendation
is to go back to just being friends with
these guys get out of doing business get
out of
interfering in their life get out of
thinking that their decisions are your
decisions their bank accounts or your
bank accounts their money is your money
and this is hard because you love them
let them know how you guys got a few
months and then i gotta rent this out
because i gotta make some money
oh bro it's bullcrap dude yep it is you
can even buy
buy drinks you can do it um you can take
them all out to dinner or something
but at the end of the day love them
you can love them all day long but you
can't save them but you can't save them
thank you so much for that call hey
everybody uh we gotta get paige let's uh
take a quick break we'll be right back
[Music]
one of the most common questions folks
ask me is what they should do when
anxiety or panic strikes you know like a
lightning bolt
and i've been helping folks one-on-one
for years but i wanted to create
something that everyone could use
anywhere at any time
so i created a free guided meditation
and it's not really a meditation
but really just me walking with you
through your anxiety
alarms from start to finish and i'll
guide you through a breathing exercise
show you how to lean in listen and head
towards healing
it's free and for everyone even you
tough hard chargers right you can
download this guided meditation today
for free
at johndaloni.com hey what's up we are
back
for this next call we weren't able to
connect with the caller
but i really loved the email and i
wanted to spend a few minutes
talking about this and so the email came
in to
kelly through john delaney.com show this
is one of the ones she didn't
automatically just hit delete on which
she does all of the time because she's
angry so so angry
um not really she's kind and beautiful
and all the things um so kelly tell us
about this email
all right so this was ann from fresno
was emailing in
about her mom's habits and her
grandparents keep bailing her out
so mom has is running a business a bar
and restaurant
continually running it into the ground
uh grandma's paying
about five thousand a month to keep that
a afloat
and then she likes to gamble the dog
and thinks that she's doing some drugs
she married a guy that then stole some
money and put a bunch of money on a
credit card
our pets heads are falling off all of it
man
yeah so she's continually making these
bad choices and the grandparents are
continuing to bail her
out and she wants to know how can she
talk to her grandparents
and tell them to stop enabling her how
old is this daughter does it say
no but it sounds like she is grown okay
wow so what do you think
i think that i mean should should they
stop enabling her yes but
they the granddaughter can't make them
do that no she can state her case and
she can say
here's what i think i think you're
enabling mom but it's their decision
that's their daughter yeah that's their
decision to make
yeah that's my recommendation there when
whenever an adult has a relationship
with another adult
and they had this burning desire to have
a conversation
the two things that guide me number one
is that person able to hear me
is this conversation do i need to say
something because it's
because i just gotta say it or can they
actually hear this conversation so
that's number one
would your grandparents actually sit
down and entertain this right
the second thing would be go ahead and
have a conversation
why are you not just going so when
everyone
anyone asks me hey how do i have this
conversation my answer is always
just have the conversation map out what
you're gonna say
write down some bullet points so it
doesn't get all chaotic and weird and
your head just starts swirling your
heart's racing and
sometimes people cry sometimes people
get fired up and angry write down what
your thoughts are
let your grandparents know hey i wanna
have a conversation and then let them
know
i think your your monthly cash infusion
of up to five
thousand dollars is contributing to my
mom making some really bad life choices
and then here's the thing there's a
period at the end of that sentence at
the end of that conversation
and then it's over you can't hold the
outcome you can't be mad at your
grandparents because that is their
daughter
some of this behavior is probably long
time coming right it's been it's been
happening for a long time
and you his daughter have to have a now
what conversation with yourself
you have it you put it out there and you
got to move on and you got to be ready
for mom to call you and say how dare you
how dare you take away my livelihood how
dare you
go around my back and talk to my parents
how dare you fill in the blank all kinds
of nonsense that how dare you people
say right but you got to be ready to
burn that bridge with mom you got to be
ready to burn that bridge with
grandparents
and you got to make sure that they can
hear this conversation
all of that means it's probably the
right thing to do
you probably need to have a hard
conversation and maybe your grandparents
just need permission
probably not they're probably going to
keep on doing what they're doing but at
least you can sleep well knowing
i kept a cool head i
let people know it was on my heart i
spoke honestly and openly
i put all my cards on the table i love
my mom and i don't want to see her
drink or um
die young because she's making bad
decisions she can't run a business
clearly she needs to
get a regular job and i don't my
grandparents to
end up destitute because they were
supporting their daughter i think that
conversation is noble and good you just
got to do it the right way
and again for grandparents can't hear it
they can't hear it they can't hear it
um so thanks so much for that for that
note in there ann and thanks
kelly um was gonna make a joke about
kelly but this doesn't feel like a funny
place to make a joke so listen everybody
this is me getting mature
on the spot like live in action um
i just hate when kids feel like they
are forced into a parenting role for
their parents i can't stand that it
drives me bananas
and every almost every kid i know adult
kid
child kid feels some sort of
responsibility to make sure
their parents are okay and i just wish
parents were in a situation where they
could make better
choices they could let their kids be
loved and not
force their kids to have to parent them
that's that's the world we're in um to
the moms out there if you're
if your parents your elderly parents are
having to infuse five thousand dollars
into your failing business stop
stop stop doing that to your parents
stop doing that to your kids just quit
oh man all right let's wrap up today's
show let's get out of here let's do um
ah this one's so good off the 2001
expanded edition songs in a minor
the beautiful and talented and so
brilliant alicia keys
she every song she writes is incredible
but this song fallen
goes like this i keep on falling in and
out of love
with you sometimes i love you sometimes
you make me blue
if this wasn't romantic it might be
talking about me and kelly
sometimes i feel good at times i feel
used loving you darling makes me so
confused i keep
on falling in and out of love with you i
never love someone the way that i love
you i never felt this way
how do you give me so much pleasure and
cause me so much pain
just when i think i've taken more than
what a fool
golly i start falling back in love with
you alicia
every one of us this song is for every
one of us
i keep falling in love with you this has
been the dr john daloni show